alright guys bangbang I am here with
with my good friend Johan thanks for
doing this man thanks for having me I
feel like there's got a lot of people
are going to listen to this and be
pleasantly surprised by by you you've
kept a low profile but we're gonna
expose you right now let's jump into
into your background you spent a lot of
time on Wall Street now do a bunch of
tech investing in private markets but
maybe just walk us through kind of how
we get here sure yeah so you know I
graduated Oh two went to work right on
Wall Street went to work at Goldman sat
in front of a computer screen modeling
Excel you know valuations dislocated
structures a lot of cash flow analysis
for a couple years like most people do I
actually had Goldman transfer me over to
London within my first year and so I
spent the entirety my career in London
actually from 2003 to 2006 teen I was on
the macro proprietary trading desk so
that's like an internal hedge fund
within you know within the firm it was
the you know was the the largest
risk-taking group within the firm and so
for someone at 23 who had no experience
in trading you know no background I was
definitely no the odd man out right so I
was a young analyst soaking up knowledge
from some of the best whoever did it
really you know some of the largest risk
takers and Goldman's history they often
look to go set up their own hedge funds
and so after a few years of doing that I
moved over to credit trading where I you
know ran a relatively big book trading
credit default swaps and high-yield
bonds you know I often say Goldman's a
pretty good allocator of talent you know
sometimes they see around the curve so
there was a time a few years before when
a lot of talented people started moving
into commodities before anything had
happened and the same thing happened in
credit I moved into credit and no six
you know seven things got busier and as
you know you know in oh eight you know
that the firm was very well staffed up
to kind of you know manage that crisis
etcetera so I ran a credit derivatives
book throughout the crisis it was having
a waiting on nine no move to the buy
side and so I traded a multi-strategy
book you know at Millennium blue press
and large hedge funds so I've always
traded pretty pretty broad risk you know
equities fixed income rates mockney's
etc and as you said now
running a firm in LA which is focused on
private investments got it let's talk
about the navigating the crisis
obviously that's got some parallels
today some differences but maybe just
like what were your big lessons learned
given that not only did you kind of go
through the crisis but you're actually
trading the exact assets that were at
the center of that crisis yeah yeah it
was a trial by fire you know I mean you
never really know you never really know
what the importance of liquidity is
until you're really sitting front row
and center and really understanding what
it means when people can't source
including me they want I think all of us
take for granted that the market is
fully functioning at most times and even
now for the most part has been fully
functioning you know perhaps with the
exception of oil in recent days but in
general you know prices move in a
relatively linear fashion you can buy
you can sell the price might be higher
or lower but you can get things done
that was really an introduction to the
fact that if somebody doesn't want to
make a price for you in the opposite
direction that you're in there's
sometimes no exit right and so trading
that book you know for Goldman
throughout that crisis I learned a lot
about liquidity we traded that at scale
obviously and so I think some of the
lessons there as well where that you
know sometimes these things can persist
for longer than you think right the
price of liquidity is high and it's more
valuable than most people think and
actually I'm sure we'll get into it but
you know a lot of what led me to you
know to co-found this business here
which is focused on private investments
with a lot of secondary market focus the
corollaries in the parallels to trading
credit are very similar to what I think
is happening in the secondary market
with adventure now and so essentially
you know what we do now is we provide a
lot of liquidity for early investors or
the employees etc and I think it was
that appreciation of knowing that you
know the quitting the only matters when
you need it you know you only know you
need it when you need it and so I think
those were some of those and we're
seeing that you know over the last
couple of weeks in the market you know
public markets today right is there a
complete you know price just fell off a
cliff in many many asset classes and
it's because people literally were
looking for that liquidity yeah yeah
it's right you look for it and you know
and you have to you know
you learn you know you learn how to
trade sighs just why you go in the hedge
fund world I think the same is true and
venture which the capacity constrain
business but you know it's different
putting you know a million dollars to
work in the market and a billion dollars
to work right and it's not just the
psychology and the fear around trading
large sizes there's actually a different
way that you have to learn how to move
large blocks of risk in and out of the
market and so when you see some of these
top hedge funds former as these large
asset managers managing these books that
are you know 100 500 times the scale of
an advert asset manager it's really a
whole nother dimension to the to the
risk analysis and the skill set right
it's not just picking the right
investments at the right time there's
different ways you have to move in and
out of a risk when you're managing large
books of that size and so even though
the venture capital markets a lot
smaller you know the risk I was trading
Goldman was large in the moderate sized
market here in venture the markets
relatively small and so everybody has to
understand how to move relatively large
blocks of risk around when the time
comes
yeah and you mentioned risk a couple
times and I think that people who are
unfamiliar with the mentality on Wall
Street right the best of the best
it's all about risk right and it's
understanding that risk pricing that
risk probabilities of the recession
occurring and so like that maybe any
lessons learned over your career given
the various asset classes that you
traded where risk like hey this is the
one or two lessons I learned that really
stick out my head and now you've brought
that to the business today yeah yeah you
know I think one of the large lessons
learned is that you know unless you're
in the sea
unless you're managing the risk right
your opinions on the matter are very
qualitative in speculative the best
right so you often see traders you know
they don't want to know what you think
about the market just tell me your
position right if you're bullish how
long are you right I'll judge your
conviction based on that if you're
bearish out shorter you I think in a
market right now where as we were
talking about earlier a lot of people
have and go bid on the market etc if you
don't have skin in the game right if
you're not managing any feeling that
risk as it oscillates and as it goes up
and down um you're really doing a very
different job and people know that the
people managing the risk right so I
think for me you know some of the
lessons there are I think going into
training I thought that
objected to treating was to predict the
future essentially right you know I used
to laugh with my flatmate about it you
know I thought that I had been given a
job where I was gonna be paid to learn
about everything in the world it's
multifactorial job right where there's
an infinite amount of inputs really
fascinating right what the taxi driver
taxi driver said mattered with the CEO
it mattered and you can sort of take all
these inputs from around the world and
crystallize it into a trading view and
try to predict what's gonna happen next
what the job really is I think at least
you know in my in my humble opinion is
it's about understanding when there's a
set up in the market where even if you
can't predict the possibility the
probability of what's happening next you
know that if X happens the return might
be 10 X and if the opposite effect
happens the return might be negative 1 X
right and if you can put yourself in
situations where even if you don't have
any idea I think we're a perfect
situation now right where we're faced
with unknowable risk right there are a
lot of opinions we really have no way to
quantify when we're going back to work
what the long-term economic impacts are
etc and so trying to position your
portfolio by predicting what we think
will happen with the coronavirus is a
recipe for disaster
right that's relatively unknowable and
the market is smarter than any
individual person right it's the sum
total of millions and millions of people
voting right billions of people and so
but what if you can find investments
that you know that if there's an equal
probability of two events occurring
which is generally that the base case
for something which is unknowable if you
can put yourself in risk/reward
situations where the reward is multiples
larger than the risk you know you do
that systematically and do that over
time
and that's and that's how the great
investors make money you know I think I
think one of the other things I learned
is that the hit rate of the great
investors is not necessarily
meaningfully larger than the hit rate of
the good investor you know they're both
better than the hit rate of the average
or the not or the novice right but we're
talking about single-digit percentage
points right many edge fund managers are
right 55 to 60 percent of the time would
be a very large number right but the
magnitude of what they make when they're
right
versus the magnitude of what they lose
when they're wrong is very very
different and so I think that investors
and traders have to really understand
and be honest with themselves about when
they feel like the risk reward is truly
skewed and to know when to really push
the chips in and so that kind of bet
sizing investment sizing risk management
is often more important you know than
just getting the right or wrong with you
right because because we all we all get
them right wrong yeah and I guess how do
you think about that let's take all for
example right so we're recording this
right after oil went negative for the
first time ever and I think a lot of
people would have said to you the lowest
price point that oil can trade it is
zero dollars right and then all of a
sudden now in hindsight it's like oh
well yeah it does make sense that
somebody would pay you to take the oil
they can't store you kind of everything
that we saw happened yes right right
how do you think through the like
there's the known risk and then there's
the unknown risk or the unknown downside
right and kind of how you you put that
into a framework and it's weird cuz you
know that you don't know something and
so how do you actually evaluate yeah
it's interesting you know and I think
the corollary from my side thinking
about equity and credit as well you know
which I traded more of a critical oil is
that there's often a very appealing
strategy broadly speaking right which is
short volatility which is the idea
you're essentially collecting premium
for for some sort of reason right and
you can either be explicitly short
volatility right you can be selling
options but there are lots of other ways
to be implicitly short volatility right
where the idea is that if something
unknowable or unexpected happens you can
lose a lot more money than you think
right and the flip side of that is you
know essentially the insurance model
right and so it's very tantalizing to in
some way shape or form be short
volatility because you're right often
right people like being right often
right and kind of you make money on a
consistent basis and you feel like
you're doing something right and the
flip side of that is if your loan
volatility you also have to wait large
periods of time right it's a very
painful job waiting for something
unusual to happen but when it happens
obviously the magnitude of it is very
very high
so I think about that because I think
you know you often have risks in your
portfolio especially you know when
you're new to it this investor that you
didn't really know you had to the idea
that a front month oil future contract
can go negative is not something that a
lot of people would have expected right
the idea that you might be short an
option and had convexity which means as
the position goes against you not only
do you lose money but the position gets
larger and larger right and
theoretically you know we can understand
that from a mathematical perspective
until you've set in a sea and realized
that as the position goes against you
and grows you have to swim faster and
faster just to tread water
you know it's what makes a lot of the
great hedge fund managers implicitly
long volatility all the time
you know they refused to sell tail
options right they refused to be short
that kind of risk because even if they
can't foresee you know around the corner
as to what might happen they know that
when those things do happen you know
it's career risk right or it's personal
financial disaster right so I think you
know it takes it takes a lot of
diligence to make sure you're looking at
positions and being honest with yourself
right about why you're entering it what
the unknown unknowns really are and
whether or not on in some way shape or
form you're trying to pick up you know
pennies in front of a steamroller or
whatever they know that she is right and
to make sure you really quantify that
correctly right because you know it
could be negative oil it could be
negative convexity and a you know an
option portfolio and there are many many
other examples of it right we works a
good example right where you thought
that there were certain risks and it
turned out that counterparty risk and
then it turned out you had new layers of
risk regs and saga just continues to
grow and grow and so that's one of the
reasons why you know a lot of people who
are long-term investors who've made it
in their careers long enough to still be
in the game right which is a large part
of it is if they often have some sort of
tail hedging right some sort of risk
which they expect to lose money but
which is you know meant acts as a kind
of a what-if edge to the portfolio right
and you learn that it's worth paying
that fee - yeah
in part of this too is there's obviously
the difference in the public and private
markets right the public markets in
theory there supposed to be more access
to information cut off there's an even a
more even playing field in terms of what
people know but there's obviously a very
big difference in how that information
is interpreted and kind of your position
on it the private markets not so much
let me talk a little bit about how you
viewed the difference between those
public and private markets and then
we'll get into what you guys are doing
at bracket yeah sure good question yeah
so you know actually that um that
apprehension or that acknowledgement
that the markets you know are relatively
efficient in the public markets you
don't really have an asymmetric
advantage with respect to access to
information you don't have an asymmetric
advantage in terms of access to price
right the prices are on the screens for
the most part in trading the same as
everyone else and really although I
think a lot of people based their
analysis on this
you know the analysis that you can have
about the company which broadly shares
this information is relatively
homogeneous as well right there's very
little that you could know about Amazon
that I couldn't know if we both were
willing to do the right amount of work
right the information is essentially
there it's known and in the market with
quants and algos and you know research
teams doing unbelievable amounts but now
is this there's very little edge in
terms of analytical information right
which i think is not what the banks are
selling you right they're selling you
that they've been able to analyze this
company better than the people but the
truth is is that you know generally
speaking people have access the same
information they come to relatively
similar conclusions right I think
there's some hindsight bias in terms of
people explaining why they got things
right or wrong private markets are
exactly the opposite right and that's
actually why I moved from one to the
other I think that after being on the
buy side being in public markets broadly
speaking for 15 or so years and you've
seen how average hedge fund returns have
declined right in that 80's and 90's
when some of the luminaries you know
we're putting up 30% plus a year right
many of those same people have closed
down their hedge trunks right
unable to break even in a market right
and it's not because they're not as
smart as they were 20 years ago
is because the game has changed the
amount of capital was arbitrage the way
opportunity's faster and so I think that
you'll I think
most people would would not acknowledge
that if you see truly outsize
performance there's some level of
asymmetry or dislocation alongside some
very hard diligence and some fundamental
work and analysis right so when I was
thinking about the next step in my
career I'm from California thinking
about when they come back home you know
when to make make the next transition I
was looking for a market that was
asymmetric right
I wanted a market where there was
imperfect information where there was
imperfect access to information
imperfect access to supply where there
were more unknowables right because if
you're on the right side of an asymmetry
you have the chance for true alpha right
for true outperformance relative to a
benchmark and so I specifically targeted
venture you know I've been a tourist in
it right I'm an angel investing with
some friends we even met before I set up
bracket writing so I was investing in
some funds and some individual companies
and I was very intrigued by the fact
that that the information was so opaque
right and that was a draw for me right
and I feel like I've seen markets moved
from opacity to transparency the credit
market is a great example you know and I
think all more is moving that direction
because you know capital is efficient
right and when there's an inefficient
outcome to the positive side a lot of
people enter that space until until it
sort of you know becomes more
transparent and more efficient so
looking into venture I looked adventurer
in private markets and thought okay this
is an inefficient area with great upside
great innovation innovation you know I'm
long human potential in general as a
person I'm an optimist you know I feel
like disruption of incumbents as a theme
which is accelerating etc and so I was
curious about that and then even within
venture I kind of went a level lower and
thought what is the most commoditized
homogenous area of access within venture
right I want to be sure to stay away
from that and why am I thought at the
beginning with a few notable exceptions
of some firms that have got some
unbelievable Network effects but by and
large early stage investing which was
sort of a niche profession by true
enthusiasts is now you know an area
where there are thousands of fund
managers right putting billions of
dollars to work right and the amount of
exits have not increased right and so
the valuations have gone up competition
has gone up right some of those
signaling effects and some of those
Network benefits
various different networks within
Northern California in particular etc
have become a lot more commoditized just
because there are so many more people
doing it just as smart probably and
distant talented as the people who
generated outside returns
a decade ago in that space but from a
supply and demand perspective the
returns can only fall relative to
history in that area right when you have
more capital chasing the same outcomes
but I became intrigued by this you know
sub-sector you know this niche within
venture which is the secondary markets
right which is essentially you know what
is an employee do when there are five
seven nine years into a private company
they've got a lot of stock but there's
no liquid market for them to access that
the quiddity there's no way for them to
buy a house and plan for their family
etc employees or the investors and so
bracket does a number of things I'm sure
we'll talk about it
but one of the most acute areas that we
began to look at was we think that over
time the secondary market for venture
will be larger than the primary market
right secondary markets in general are
larger than the primary mark the stock
market is secondary market right the
housing market except for new builds is
a secondary market and the bond markets
a secondary market right and so this
company stays private longer and there
are more people with trap liquidity on
the cap table you know we think it's the
right thing to do because we think those
people should have access that putting
they are did right by their stock
options and those company and we also
think that the market will gravitate
towards that way and so we begin a
strategy which is relatively focused you
know we live in that and so before we go
deeper there what else is this bracket
do can I give us a full overview and
then we'll go into really the second
area Marcus I think that's a key piece a
lot people don't understand and
obviously is it's quite attractive
sure so you know in in essence you know
we're an investment management firm you
know were a few years old I co-founded
it with my partner Delta on 2017 and
essentially what we're looking to do is
operate in areas of asymmetry
where we think that there are dislocated
opportunities they can generate outsized
returns right and given you know my
background in our background we have a
relatively wide aperture terms ooh
open-mindedness in terms of what that
might be
right if that was in the credit markets
that was in the equity markets that was
in subsets of that market you know we're
we have experience he sort of all those
areas but one of the things I also
learned from my time trading is it is
very easy to be too broad right there's
a lot of good ideas and there are very
few great ideas and there were very few
great ideas that also are symmetrical
with your personal skill set right there
might be a great idea but your
personality or your network or your
background may not make you an a player
in that area right and so to find an
area where you think you can be a player
and find that area it's actually
opportunity learn oment in time is rare
right I think it's easy to be too broad
I think it's easy to be too diversified
actually with respect to your time in
your focus right the founders know this
better than anyone right they can
demoniacal about about the one thing
they're doing and so when we started
Bracken you know there was a lot of
things that we could do but we decided
to only focus on places where we thought
the opportunity was ten out of ten
and where we thought that our skill set
was kind of attendance so we started
only within private markets and venture
right and we focus on growth and late
stage companies so that's the growth
bucket is anywhere from companies worth
sort of two hundred million to a billion
broadly speaking and then the late stage
bucket is companies they're so famous
right worth of billion plus so those are
companies which will go to IPO or M&A
presumably and much shorter timeframe
right so the duration is shorter the
liquidity return of cash to investors is
faster and higher we spend the vast
majority of our time there but we're
also interested in other sort of
emerging areas are interested in private
credit right there's some symmetrical
kind of relationships and networking
advantages to sort of what we do all day
on the venture side and how that can be
put to work within private credit um at
a time when you know at least a few
months ago the market was at all-time
highs correlation was at all-time highs
didn't think that was the most opportune
time to be spending time in
markets right you may get it right or
wrong but you don't have a true
competitive advantage at least we didn't
think from our perspective so we spent
no time there over time as volatility
picks up and this is like one of the
themes of bracket essentially where
we're positioned for volatility it could
be to the downside or to the upside but
we embrace volatility right essentially
all our strategies have a long
volatility sort aperture and in a focus
and so when markets dislocate
you know when large moves happen and I
think we're entering a world in which
large things are going to happen more
frequently we get drawn to those areas
and so we're beginning to invest in
crypto we spend a lot of time investing
in late stage venture you know we're
looking a lot more public markets
recently and you know in terms of the
roadmap of where things might go and I
think broadly speaking that can all be
encapsulated by the fact that over the
last decade or so passive investing
right indexing through for days etc
mutual funds has really taken over the
investment landscape right it's actually
driven a lot of active managers out of
business because why say you know why
pay somebody to in 20 when you can get a
lower almost fee free you know kind of
structure by a any number of mutual
funds right and outperform the market
and that's because this wave of
liquidity that the Fed and local central
banks have unleashed just lifted all
boats right and relatively speaking a
great boat might perform a little bit
better than a good boat but essentially
they're all up were drifting in such a
consistent fashion that the dispersion
between the two you know was was
relatively low in the correlation was
very very high right so it didn't make a
lot of sense to pay an active manager
I think that's changed right I think the
area of passive investing is essentially
over and I think that's one of the
biggest bubbles in the market you know
we talked about unknown risks right so
many of us have our 401ks and our
families etc and these ETFs these
trackers most people don't even know
what's in them right they don't know how
it's calculated they don't know how
liquid that future that ETF might really
be or not be in a time of severe
distress and so we want to allocate our
time to active management right to more
tactical investing with
long term horizon but with tactical
investing in between and so Brackett is
doing all those things right but in
terms of the funds that we manage now
the vast vast majority of the capital we
manage is focused on private markets
simply because we think it's the largest
dislocation the most amount of asymmetry
and so we want to focus our time yeah
it's interesting I think because there's
a lot of people who would look at the
various assets or markets that you're
looking at and say wow how can they say
that they are you know have a single
strategy right that there's so many
different assets or so many different
markets but actually and I'm cheating
because I know you and we've talked
about it before is you can take very
similar frameworks and very similar
approaches and what you're really doing
is you're looking for that dislocation
right is to maybe talk a little bit
about like when you're analyzing either
a new asset class or a market like what
are the things you're looking at that
say yes this fits kind of that
dislocation type theme or it doesn't
what is that evaluation process so when
we think about dislocations and
asymmetries generally we think about it
kind of along three axes right the first
is price so in a liquid market we all
pay the same price more or less right
the price as I said for Amazon is the
same as for me
and in private markets it's very
different right you may get a different
price because at the time you entered
based on your relationship based on the
value add you may or not bring to the
company based on whether you're buying
directly from the company itself or
whether you're buying from an employee
or an early investor right if we're
buying from an angel investor who's up
100x on the position right they may
value the the speed to liquidity a
little bit higher than eating out those
extra few percent right which may be
somebody else's entire strategy they
play for so you know in the broadest of
senses you know we're trying to pay fair
price and not pay premiums for
everything that we're investing right
and you have to be a price taker in most
markets but in things which are kind of
over-the-counter so to speak that are
that are not traded on exchanges that
could be a house that could be a piece
of art that could be a you know an
access to a private private company
right those prices are not really set
in the same way and so there's a more
interpersonal aspect there's a aspect of
negotiation and there's just there's
elements there that give you some
flexibility to pay the right or wrong
price depending upon you know a thing on
your analysis right people can differ
more widely in terms of their fair value
analysis of that type of price right and
so it doesn't always mean that one
person is right or wrong it might just
mean that it's an opaque asset people
value it a little bit different so you
know we look for price from a nascent
asymmetric standpoint access is another
asymmetric standpoint
right the great companies within private
markets are in high demand right and so
when you think about the ability to even
access that company if you had the cash
and if you had the willingness you know
a founder generally has earned the right
to be choosy right a successful founders
are on the right to be choosy you know
this as well as anyone right so you know
what your brand is what your network is
what else you're bringing to the table
right you're in a personal skill is how
you manage relationships all those
things kind of come to bear upon not
only what price you might pay but you
know if somebody's issuing one hundred
million dollars of stock in a new
financing and they've got seven hundred
million dollars of interest who gets
that right and different people have
different ways of managing and kind of
making themselves appealing so to speak
right to that founder or to that seller
so you want to mark it for more
perspective where access is not totally
egalitarian right it's not totally
modernized and so then you want to play
your strengths you know in terms of the
ways in which you wish you access right
but you were given access to those kinds
of things and then from a timing
perspective this is one of the you know
perhaps the benefits of being an
outsider so to speak you know to venture
and bringing a different lens you know
they're always benefits and negatives to
being lonely steeps kind of in an area
right and also to having you know fresh
fresh lens on things right for more
perspective we look at primary
financings and venture which you know is
essentially when a company goes out and
raises money for investors right and
those typically happen you know once
every year or two
right depending upon the needs of the
company etc and all the interest from
investors is focused on that one route
right so it's the most competitive time
to invest invariably that competition
leads to higher prices right and there's
no particular asymmetric advantage there
you know from our perspective of wealth
we prefer to be more fluid right I guess
this is sort of the trader in me you
know in our in our firms DNA is that we
like to be able to enter a position when
we think that it's reached an inflection
point not just when the company is
decided it is time to raise their series
D or their Series B right so we do
impressive invest in primary around the
home you think that's the opportune time
but also because we have the flexibility
to do secondaries as well the round is
never closed so to speak right we may do
some primary and secondary who makes use
one versus the other and so we look at
all that alongside what I would say is
sort of table stakes analysis which is
the fundamental diligence the valuation
work the comparative company in Dallas
is growth rate analysis the analysis
team I feel like if you're not doing
that well clearly you know you're not
set up for success anyway but I think
that's baseline right and above that you
have to think about what else are you
doing and you know that's the way in
which we've you know which we decide to
approach it and so what this brings them
is if there's not that equal access to
information right there there is an
opportunity for the dislocation there's
obviously winners and losers in those
markets right and access to information
is one of the key components how do you
think about gaining information both
kind of you know market driven stuff but
then also either company or
opportunities specific in a market where
you can't just go login to a Bloomberg
and you know type in a symbol and all a
sudden there's everything you need to
know right yeah you know that's also one
of the nuances of venture that makes it
particularly information is out there
but you have to know how to find it
right you have to you have to know who
find it from you have to know where to
look for it you'll piece things together
and triangle a different way I think
that's one of the things that makes a
little more interesting exciting you
know in the hedge fund side I was
sitting behind
screams for 15 years you know almost 24
hours a day right up at night look at
the Asian markets during the day trading
here from the US here there's not that
constant information flow and there as
you say ry hey cemeteries you know some
people can find that information out
with a single phone call right other
people may have to find that information
out through dozens of reference checks
and triangulations and some investments
you have you have two direct line in
that kind of a way it's very easy call
some is very difficult right you got to
nurture a manufacturer wait which to get
access that information and I think
those dislocations you know those
inequities right or what what kind of
present the opportunity right and so so
we think about all that you know it's a
it's a large part of the diligence it's
not just how do you analyze the
information but how do you go about
finding the information you know that
you want to analyze right and there's a
lot of qualitative and subjective things
with respect to private companies as
well right I mean these companies are
often growing so fast you know if you're
looking at the right ones that
historical analysis is useful you have
to do it but the future doesn't
necessarily look like the past where is
it you're in a public company with a
three to five percent growth rate it's
been around for 50 years right tomorrow
looks pretty similar right in most
instances to today right and so that
kind of historical analysis is more
valuable there right here you have to
add an extra dimension where you have to
be able to understand and think
exponentially and I think even you know
even government responses to this crisis
right individual responses to this
crisis show it's very difficult for us
to fathom exponential growth right even
if we understand it conceptually it's
hard to hard to imagine it if you
haven't experienced it which is why I
think some of the compounding benefits
to investing in seeing these kinds of
things take place right once you've seen
it and you've felt it we talked about
negative convexity to the downside when
you've seen good positive convexity to
the upside and know it's possible you
know in your bones as opposed to just on
paper you approach investing you know
sometimes I'm sorry
yeah one of the things I think venture
investors obviously and
but those that don't understand the
venture market is it the public markets
we would all do a bunch of speculating
do a lot of research do a lot of
estimations as to you know what is the
earnings report gonna show or what are
the key metrics going to show at kind of
these predefined points in time we all
will speculate in the market buy sell
hold whatever and then there's kind of
this like reveal of the numbers everyone
all at once
and then some action happens to the
price but in the private markets that
information one is much more robust and
also two is heavily driven by access
that's granted by the team itself right
so if you're an existing investor for
example you can go and see the
financials the user growth all these
kind of metrics pretty much whenever you
want or whatever they'll allow you if
you're not an existing investor
obviously you can ask right you can you
can kind of triangulate to things but
there is greater access to information
which then can drive investment
decisions which I think gives an
advantage right but kind of how do you
think about that you know not only the
persistent access but also the types of
information you can get in the private
market versus what you get in the public
market yeah yeah good question um I
think also you know to overlay with that
what it also comes down to is you always
have some imperfect information right
you can have the balance sheet sitting
right in front of you you can be talking
to the CEO but people misjudge those
things all the time right they're
unknowable or difficult to judge
otherwise a market would already move to
that price and so I think as an investor
you have to appreciate that you're
always operating within perfect
information right a public market
investor might think they have more
information than a private market
investor and that may or may not be the
case as well right in the public company
you have those financials easier access
that you have to work a little harder
flow on the private side on the private
side you might actually know the
management team right it's pretty
difficult to get stuck on the phone if
you want to buy a 50 shares of Facebook
something like that right whereas in the
private markets a little bit different
so I think if you're comfortable with
uncertainty right if you're comfortable
with the fact that you don't know
everything right then I think you take a
step back and you say in any market
with any access to information should I
bet everything in one go right answer is
obviously no then if you say what if I
Institute a process whereby if I can do
something ten or a hundred or a thousand
times right knowing that there are
certain imperfections in terms of not
only the information but my ability to
analyze it and also what may happen
tomorrow from you dodging is immense
like we're going to now cetera can you
say that this process itself if I stick
to it over time it will tilt you know
tilt the scales right till the balance
of the scale is in my direction
and then I can have predictable outcomes
at a portfolio level over time right and
so that's also essentially what we're
trying to do right I think that you know
the idea here is that you know we have a
certain process both fundamental and
qualitative right some of those
investments you know could go better
than expected or worse than expected but
I think one of the benefits about coming
from the hedge fund side for me is that
you know I put on probably somewhere
between you know one and fifty trades a
day for fifteen years something like
that right and the feedback loop is
almost immediate and that's very
valuable right I mean I think operators
talk about that when they say you want
to iterate you push product and get the
feedback it's hard to iterate on your
investment style in venture if you have
to wait ten years to know if you're
right or wrong yet right and it's hard
to know if you're right or wrong just by
looking at whether or not one investment
that you made at sea made money or not
because maybe you made money for the
thesis that you thought these companies
pivot dozens of times along the way
right and so it's it's it's much more
difficult to measure yourself and if you
can't measure yourself and it's hard to
adapt right and I think one of the
things that I feel quite strongly about
in terms of the market you know
especially the public markets it really
drew me to it was the philosophical side
right in the introspective side of it
any idea that you know this is a this is
a game right this is an experience where
you know you're right or wrong because
the ticker is telling you every single
second of every single day right and so
if you're honest and if you're
if you're willing to change if you're
willing to learn from your own mistakes
as opposed to ignore them right find
yourself blaming the market you know
you're probably in the wrong position
right probably in the wrong seat right
but if you look at what you're doing and
you're you know you're kind of analyzing
your own patterns you may begin to see
after those ten thousand hours twenty
thousand hours thirty thousand dollars
did I'm very good at this kind of a set
up and actually this kind of a set up
over here then I thought that I was good
at writing that I had conviction in I've
learned over time through the pain of
losing money right getting things wrong
then um I'm just not graded that right
and so if you then tend to do more what
works right and unless of what doesn't
which isn't a given because we're all
quite stubborn and you have to sort of
fight against yourself within this but I
think you know from my perspective when
I when I met and sat around some of
these great investors when I was 23 and
they were in their 40s at the top of
their game I was I was learning from
square one the consistency that I saw
across all of the truly great investors
who I've been around are things like
that it's humility flexibility you know
honesty and I think that the perception
that create investors know have large
egos at least in my experience that's
true of the above average investor right
making enough money to feel overly
confident but the truly great investors
really respect the market right and they
don't base too much of their decision on
a particular outcome they're really
focused on their process right and
they're focused on worth finding that
process over time and so you know I kind
of took that short feedback loop right
high frequency like experience and you
know we're overlaying some of those
learnings you know on to this private
market where you do generally have to
wait a long time to find things out
right and so I think that's one of the
benefits from working an area where you
really touch and feel the market every
day and
yeah yeah and it feels like I know you
said previously like that the market you
know or that game is really a game of
psychological and emotional discipline
right kind of what you're talking about
here I think that there's two ways to
look at this right one is hey I am in
the market and I don't have that
feedback loop but also if you look
around the room nobody else has that
feedback loop as well right and so it's
almost like you know this could be a
disadvantage or if I understand that
everyone's kind of got the same
disadvantage can I actually use this to
my advantage which I think you guys have
done very well right yeah that's right
and I think also one of the things
you'll find as well as that there's
really no formula for being a good or
great or successful investor I think
that what one needs to do is understand
their self and then understand the
market opportunity and try and bring
those you know in line right like we
were saying earlier you know they're a
short seller is a great example right
you look at the chart of the S&P 500
over the last you know 50 80 years etc
tough market to be short right it
basically looks like a 45 degree line
more or less up into the right some
short sellers have been you know
successful others haven't but you're
wrong clearly much more often than
you're right right and so it's not a
good or bad thing but some people have
the stomach to be wrong nine times out
of ten you know 99 times out of 100 and
have that one pay for the rest early
stage ventures is a little bit like that
as well right there's like power law
right great fun portfolios are not a lot
of you know a 5x fund is not a lot of
moderate exits
you know it's typically one driver or
two compensating for many many losses
right and that can be very effective but
not for everyone and only if you have
the stomach to be wrong for long periods
of time
right there are other people who might
need more consistent positive feedback
it might be like a streaky shooter in
basketball right you know if you get hot
and you feel good you're playing from
the front foot right or if you come out
of the gate and attract me first versus
last you know there are openers and
closers etcetera and so I think one of
the things in the market is know you
want to study you want
study all the external things that you
can but you also really want to keep a
close eye on yourself and understand
where your own personal strengths and
weaknesses lie and then you want to
construct an investment strategy which
plays to those strengths and wins it's
right but you just hate losing money if
it throws you off all the time right
then any investing is a difficult job
for you but B you should be taking you
know short stop losses right you should
be in setups that have a high
probability of winning but perhaps a low
magnitude of the winnings when you win
right if you're kind of somebody who's
built with more of a homerun mentality
right if that works for you and not
because you want it to work for you
because it actually works for you you
know then you can take a different
approach right so I think that you know
one of the things we try to do and every
time we bring on a new hire we're
bringing in a whole new psychology to
the firm and so one of the interesting
things about you know Co running your
own firm is you're also trying to bring
people who have a different perspective
than you right have different strengths
weaknesses you know versus yourself and
then you know create a portfolio and a
platform where you know everybody's
doing as much of what they're great at
as possible and as little whether or not
yeah that home ready homerun mentality I
think there's two pieces of this and so
in the venture world the idea of being a
contrarian is so overblown that people
hear the word they wanna throw up at
this point but but but I do think that
this homerun mentality is important
because when everyone has consensus
around an idea a trend a company you
know whatever it is there's a lot of
commoditization in the returns right now
the returns go down as more people
believe something is going to happen
this is how markets work so maybe talk a
little bit about where you guys see hey
you know we've got a different opinion
and if we're right it'll pay off but we
up fully understand if we're wrong
you know we lose money and I'm kind of
what are those areas that you guys
believe could potentially fit into that
yeah yeah yeah great question so you
know I spend a lot of time thinking
about what's consensus
in the market right sometimes we're in a
consensus trade sometimes we're not
right and not every aunty consensus
trade is right not every consensus trade
is wrong but it's important to be honest
with yourself and when you know that
your any consensus trade to beyond our
right you're very careful when you know
i mean i think i think these feedback
loops that we have in twitter and stuff
like that are also particularly
dangerous right you know your newsfeed
as we know from elections etc you know
it morphs into some sort of a mirror
right and if you're a market news feed
right where you get your information or
whose ideas you follow are essentially a
reflection or an amplification of your
own you may you may misunderstand the
risks right so if we're just thinking
high level you know what are some very
consensus opinions right I mean one that
I believe in that I think we both
believe in right now is that this money
printing machine that central banks and
governments are on is problematic and
must eventually lead to a debasement of
fiat currency versus quote-unquote hard
assets right be that gold Bitcoin or
something else right um that's a very
strong view of mine and ours right we're
very bullish that idea but also slightly
concerned that it seems the consensus
all right and so if there was a washout
lower in those kinds of assets at the
exact moment when we're increasing our
balance sheet by historic proportions
you know on an almost daily basis that
wouldn't be surprising right so how
would we approach the situation like
that where we'd say consensus opinion
but strongly held and agreed with on our
side perhaps we would size that position
to say if it goes up from here we're
happy obviously we're in the money
right but if it goes down from theater
materially in a sense we're also happy
because we've been looking for a chance
to buy more right and so the risk
management if you can find yourself in a
position where psychologically you're
happy if the move in the investment goes
with you or against you right that's a
great position to be in
psychologically a lot a trade conference
if you're too big right which we you
know which which human nature
often leads us to be right you really
believe in something you're all-in then
it goes down by a little bit it doesn't
invalidate invalidate thesis right the
reason it went down may have nothing to
do with the reason you thought it was
going to go up but it's painful right
and so people bail at the lows right and
always will right I mean that's just
literally how we're made as humans right
so that's the consensus opinion which we
agree with right a consensus opinion
that I think is also you know perhaps we
don't agree with is that you know it's
very natural to think that the stock
market is a reflection of the economy
right so to say who could say that the
economy is stronger in April 2020 you
know than it was on March 24th for
example right who's to say that we're
looking at an all-time record year in
terms of GDP growth and employment right
we know these things are bad right we
know they may get worse right but the
market is not the economy right there
are correlations between the two but
they're not one for one in the inputs
and outputs differ at different times
you know sometimes deficits matter
sometimes they don't sometimes
employment matters to the market
sometimes it doesn't right and so you
know when I look at an opinion like that
I see shorts in the S&P are at all-time
highs right my Twitter feed which I try
and keep relatively bipartisan with
respect to politics and the market right
just so I can you know imbue information
from all sides you know bears have been
angry for the last couple weeks right
people are mad at the market right they
feel like it's doing the wrong thing etc
right now if I did want to be bearish up
here as well
I would be concerned right that
everything looks like the market should
go lower right and everyone thinks the
market should go lower that's generally
not a good recipe for profitability as
an investor because even if you're right
the magnitude of the move is small
because it's not surprising right what
as you know if somebody were to have you
right now that the markets about to go
to all-time highs right not that that's
our view but that would be an
interesting non consensus view if your
fundamentals were strong and your
conviction was strong and it was in
direct opposition right to common sense
right and so I think that's one of the
ways in which you know we like to
measure the fear and greed index we like
to measure it in our own hearts and
minds we like to measure it you know by
a fundamental analysis like put/call
ratios short interest and things like
that and it doesn't drive our decisions
per se but it's the factor and from my
perspective being someone who's traded
tactically for a long time it's probably
a bigger input for us than it is for
other people you know I'm someone who
does not think the market is wrong right
I don't think it's always right per se
but I'm agnostic more times that I you
know then having a strong view against
the market I think generally when you
feel like you're in a fight with the
market you probably need to reassess
whether you're you know whether your
convictions are are not loosely held as
they say right which is a good way to
approach yeah and what are the pieces
again I'm cheating because I know how
you guys treat some of the strategies
and investments is you can be contrarian
when you put an investment or position
on right so when you enter the trade or
the investment I believe something is
true that others don't and therefore
when they come around to this idea
there's a return to be made but you also
can be contrarian or ahead of the curve
on exiting a position as well and in the
public markets that's a little bit more
commoditized because people have entry
and exit points and there's a lot of
liquidity in private markets I don't
know majority at least if not you know
80 90 percent of the market is net long
till liquidity event and that liquidity
event is out of their hands right there
waiting for that MA or the wait for that
IPO you guys take a little bit of a
different strategy given the secondary
market so and we talked a little bit
about
you know what you guys look at and then
how you actually you know put this into
practice yeah sure yeah so to your point
you know we do take profit
sometimes in positions right and you
know that's natural from our perspective
you know the hedge funds I worked at at
various tight stop losses so to speak
right you could be down a very little
and you know very very small amount of
money and lose your jobs so you learn a
lot in profits to roll your stops on
positions etc and um and we take that
mentality to some degree yeah so one of
the things which does make us a little
bit different it kind of alludes to my
point earlier about the difference
opportunity set between passive active
management right is that we do take
profits right we actively manage this
portfolio and we don't necessarily
always wait for an IPO or an M&A event
or a negative event to to crystallize
profits and so we seek to return cash on
a more frequent basis right we've had
numerous exits in the last year we had
one last week
they're either partial or full where
we're selling to secondary you know
market buyers right and I think that
what's developing within the secondary
market I think this is healthy and I
think it is a win-win actually is that
you're starting to see a whole class of
investor who previously used to be a
public market only investor right there
might be a public hedge fund it might be
a high net worth individual and you know
companies used to IPO at a relatively
early stage in their lifecycle
I think Amazon IPO is some five hundred
million dollar valuation right and now
you have bike dance which is worth 100
billion and it's still Brendan right so
clearly the value creation is accruing
to the private markets much more right I
think that one of the the lessons what I
think people are slow to realize
unfortunately especially you know small
investors mom-and-pop investors retail
investors who are boxed to help the
private markets generally is that you
know you're often pitch this 60/40
portfolio for example right you got your
public equity portfolio you have your
bond portfolio well you know bonds are
negative right yielding in many
instances now so that's not a great
place to put your money in public
equities now
crystalizing so much of the gains in the
private market right from staying
private for 10 12 15 years right
accruing that value to private market
investors that by the time they go
public even if they do perform and
obviously some of them do a lot of that
value creation has been eaten out of it
right even fantastic private market
investments like uber or lyft right are
subpar
public market investments right even
pre-cana and so what you've begun to see
and I think that this is a trend which
will eventually become a tidal wave
right which is that people who used to
wait to you to buy the IPO or buy early
in a company's life cycle as a public
company or now realize the value
creation is happening you know in the
private markets by and large and there's
a new cohort of investors for increasing
you know increasingly realize that they
need to come a little bit earlier and so
you know I think there's a win-win on
both sides right you provide liquidity
for early investors to return capital
their alleys to earn the employees be
able to live their life right without
kind of being locked into you know an
option which may take 10 or 15 years to
realize you generate good returns for
your investors and then some of those
previously public market investors who I
now we deem as crossover investors so to
speak they have an opportunity at these
companies prior to the IPO right but um
at the latest stage kind of private
market activity right I think that
you're gonna see that ecosystem develop
and grow materially yeah and how do you
look at if there is much more liquidity
and those secondary markets become much
larger especially I'm venture how does
that change the public markets and is
there eventually like this blending of
the two or how do you kind of see that
transpiring yeah good question I think
that's probably the endgame right I
think you know it's the prerogative of
private companies not to share all their
information with everyone right I don't
think that will necessarily change at
the same time you know I think were I a
CEO of a startup whether it's employee
retention we're just wanting to do the
right thing
right you realize that you have to let
your employees monetize some of the
liquidity along the way
right it's not fair I think for a CEO
who always has access to liquidity right
as we've seen in some very public
examples right or a venture capitalist
who by and large has already had some
major the quiddity events in their life
right if both of those people are
telling all the employees in a company
that you need to have more skin in the
game right you need to have ninety nine
percent probably if your personal wealth
concentrated in this one private company
you have no access to liquidity you know
I don't think it's a vote against your
confidence in the business you're
working for to say I want to sell five
or ten percent of my position right
because I want to help my mom retire or
buy a house in the same zip code is my
office right and so you know I think
that way that realization is coming
right it's coming you know came for we
work employees right it's coming for
other employees even high-performing
companies who are continually waiting to
go public and that may actually be the
right thing to do perhaps from a company
perspective but I think that boards and
CEOs are realizing and will increasingly
realize that um you know there's nothing
to fear if your company is performing
well from letting some of your early
investors or somewhere on the employees
monetize along the way you just have to
do it in a controlled fashion right and
I think you don't want noise in a
secondary market distracting from the
narrative you don't want employees
trying to trade you know secondary stock
and their company all the time but
public companies have done this for a
very long time right you know I can only
speak for the actual industry but you
know as a employee at a bank you know
every single year you get a cash
component of your bonus and you get
options right those options vest over
time you have to stay at the company but
when they best you're allowed to sell
them you're allowed to sell them in
certain prescribed windows you know
within a certain time period according
to certain compliance regulations and so
I really don't see any reason why
multibillion-dollar private companies
right wouldn't afford their employees
that same kind of flexibility
I think it's right that they want to
control it to a degree but I think
probably you know tech CEOs have gone a
little bit too far with
respect to their control their desired
control generally right you don't need
50 to one voting rights necessarily
right you don't need a full prohibition
on all secondaries you know transfers in
all situations right at the same time
you don't want your employees flipping
out of your company at a Series A when
you're just getting started frankly
these are actually relatively easy to
solve as long as everybody has the same
objective right and everybody is trying
to be a good actor and so I think
whether the market forces it right or
whether people get there willingly over
time as you say I'm not sure exactly
what the structure would look like but
you know a very late stage private
company on the scale of an air B&B or
you know a bike dance or lyft or uber
part IPO you know it's not inconceivable
that somebody should be able to
eventually log on to a portal or call
their head of HR right and say that I
want to exercise some options and
someone within this window right seems
very right to me and so I think that we
have the momentum of inevitability on
our side with respect to it and you know
whether that's a year away or a decade
away I feel like that's probably the
endgame as long as companies do stay
private and continue to want to stay
private for as long as they seem to now
yeah I tend to agree with you and people
learn in hard lessons right now right so
hopefully it'll it'll change the last
person I want to talk about before we
end is you've got a very diversified set
of LPS and some of them are very large
some of them are kind of more personal
piece what was kind of those
conversations been like over the last
few weeks during this market turmoil and
how are they thinking either differently
or kind of their thoughts evolving about
various markets and then specifically
around what you guys are doing yeah
question
so you know I think that you know at the
at the most basic of levels everybody
knows you're supposed to buy low so hot
right and everybody likes to retweet
those you know Warren Buffett a per isms
and other ones write this you want to be
greedy when people are fearful and
they're reversed right the truth is is
it everybody in the market knows that
too and they've always known it but
I think everybody and perhaps because we
were talking about before the show you
know the coronavirus has been such a you
know it's been such a well documented
right kind of instance of this it wasn't
kind of limited to sort of financial
markets like it was in 2008 right this
is something everybody is seeing in
their daily life and so you know one can
ask oneself you know how many people
went all-in on March 23rd or 24th at the
lows right in the market always feels
like that at a low right this time it's
a pandemic it could be a systemic
financial issue it could be you know
something else right and so I think that
we all know our investors as well right
um as well as ourselves everybody knows
that you are supposed to be greedy
quote/unquote you're supposed to be
aggressive when others are fearful right
and people who invest with us also know
that we are not trying to pick up
pennies in front of a steamroller right
that we are long volatility and that
when things become dislocated or
asymmetric up or down you know that's an
area in which we have a lot of
confidence a lot of experience in terms
of you know generating outsized returns
and so I think everyone invested with us
everyone who you know may perhaps seek
to invest with us in the future
understands if that's the kind of
profile what they're investing at the
same time when things like this happen
right other asset classes move against
against you right people are not always
as liquid as they would like to be in
this type of a drawdown right and so I
think that you know we'll see over time
right we have committed capital funds
and we invest them over multi-year
periods etc and so I think you know
moving into the next fundraise for
example you know depending upon where
the world is know with respect to this
it will be interesting to see I think
that people know that our strategy
frankly will perform probably quite well
amongst this uncertain and backdrop and
I think that the backdrop will be
uncertain for the foreseeable future
right that's whether or not there's a
miracle vaccine tomorrow or not to your
point you say people have learned hard
lessons I think you know hopefully those
lessons were we're hard-earned and will
be rode
short lived in terms of their
application right in terms of you know
bounce back that we all hope the economy
in the world sees but either way I think
as an employee or an investor in a
private company you're going to
appreciate risk in a slightly different
way host we were post these kinds of
things you're gonna want to know that
you have a pro volatility stance to some
degree in your portfolio and you're
gonna want to make sure that you're
selling into strength and buying into
ease right and so the question is not
only will people appreciate that and
appreciate you know that that's the time
in which to be on the front foot and to
be aggressive as hard as it is
uncomfortable as it feels you know I
think that we should see discomfort to
some degree with an investing and lean
into those opportunities when there are
on risk parameters but then also there
are just real-life situations where you
know people are illiquid right people's
you know jobs are less certain than they
were before and that's one of the gonna
be unfortunate you know one of the many
unfortunate knock-on effects of this
kind of 1% 99% bifurcation right as if
you're in an actual position where even
if you've been hurt by this you've still
got enough dry powder right to act in
two extreme situations whether to the
outside of the downside you're in a much
better position right and so everyone
has to trade their own portfolio and
their own personal wealth you know
according accordingly
I mean but certainly this is the kind of
environment I'm not just talking about
stocks here I'm just talking about
dislocations generally this is the kind
of environment where if you look around
and you see that everybody else is
fearful you know if you are an optimist
if you do believe in human innovation
right if you do believe that generally
these things always feel like this to
some degree this is a very extreme
example but every example feels like an
extreme example at the time right and so
I'm not advocating to anybody be
imprudent but I I would say that you
know when everybody's calm right and
went on the cover of magazines you're
seeing tech titans and titanium Bulls on
the cover of The Economist and things
like that you know not a bad time to
monetize
a little bit more into cash you know and
when you see you know when you see this
kind of volatility not only is it a way
to support the economy right support
people right invest in businesses we
believe in and to vote with your pocket
you know it's also the right thing to do
from an investment standpoint right so I
think you know our investors we
generally raise from a relatively small
group of obviously well capitalized
individuals and you know in institutions
and so they're well well positioned
right - to add into these kinds of in
volatility know we've we've made some
recent investments we're doing two more
this week you know we continue to stay
active but on the personal level I think
that we should all you know one of the
lessons that everybody should take from
this especially if the market resolves
itself to the upside eventually which is
obviously all of our strong hope is that
you know remember remember what this
felt like right remember you know to
have a Pro volatility stats in your
portfolio to some degree you know don't
be afraid to take a little bit of profit
into winnings and I think that's good
advice for all of us that you know that
we all we all should continue to remind
ourselves a long time for sure before we
finish up I said one what their favorite
book is or the most important book what
would yours be favorite book our most
important book you know the truth is my
favorite book is Shogun you're a guy do
you know what is that really you know it
takes place in feudal Japan you know
with the samurai this guy washes up on
the shores of Japan he's the first
western to be there and and goes on to
live this you know this sort of amazing
life fictional book but um you know I'm
actually someone who you know I read a
lot but I like to go back to the same
things as well so I've probably read
that book 25 or 50 times you know I mean
I just yeah I love it
and so I'm always you know maybe over it
so I'm interested in philosophy I'm
interested in kind of introspection I'm
interested in Eastern philosophy cetera
I think being in the markets has
amplified that and so I don't know if
it's the most important or the most
useful book but it's
it's the most enjoyable one for me what
I've learned in asking that question to
so many people is the most important
book has a lot to do with what it meant
to you and and when you read it yeah
yeah this is always interesting I got a
one question for uh for everyone which
is aliens believer non-believer what are
they expecting now I'm gonna say
believer yeah why just think the odds
are if the universe is infinite right
I don't bet against you know kind of
short the unknown so I'd say somewhere
out there for sure I asked the question
because it tells a lot about the way
somebody thinks and so literally short
the unknown is a perfect way for you to
articulate why you believe what one
question do you have for me to to wrap
up yeah good question um you know
obviously we known each other for a
while I've been following you know this
podcast etc I'm curious this kind of
feedback this you know these
conversations that you're having with
people from all over I'm curious I guess
in the context of investing you know how
do you feel like you've changed as an
investor as a result of all these
interviews that you've been doing over
the past year yeah it's um
I explained to somebody literally just
yesterday and I said this is the most
selfish thing I do because basically I
can go to people who probably wouldn't
talk to me or have a conversation in
this level of detail and say hey I'll
make you a deal you come on you're gonna
have one conversation it's gonna go to a
lot of people I'm gonna ask you all the
questions that I want to know right and
just happens to be there's much other
psychos out there that I want to hear as
well and so as I've done that it really
allows me to get so many different
perspectives so many different inputs
and what you realize is that when you go
into a situation with very high level of
conviction very quickly as you hear more
and more variety in the opinions it's
not so much that you change your mind
what happens is you actually start to
calibrate the level of your
fiction right so it's still hey I
believe X I may not believe it as
strongly as I previously did or I didn't
believe something and maybe now you know
it's not a hundred percent that's wrong
it's 60 percent or whatever and so that
the severity of belief and how that gets
calibrated the more people you talk to
and then also the different types of
people right you know talking to
somebody who no one's ever heard of
before has no investing tractor
whatsoever but they're an expert on one
specific thing as you know just as much
weight if not more weight than going and
talking to the most famous investor in
the world about that same topic because
this person is an expert that you know
big investors not and so I think it's
just it's all things that we know right
but but actually going through the
process really uh as a reminder right
and and so super valuable yeah well I've
been enjoying it so hold on you yeah I
appreciate it where can people go find
you on the internet and in bracket sure
yeah no I don't know I'm not on social
media a lot but I'm on there you know
mainly collecting information
but uh Twitter I make JBL bracket
bracket capital is our website you went
on CNBC I saw you up there outside look
man look at you the guy who's hiding in
the shadows is is on TV yeah
you're in there I love me well listen
thanks for doing this I think people
really gonna enjoy this one and I will
talk soon all right you all take care